[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
en direct soyez les bienvenus dans ça
vous regarde au sommaire ce soir la
fusion de la discorde voilà après des
semaines de bras de fer que veolia le
numéro 1 français de l'eau est entrée en
force au capital du numéro de suez
opération largement contestée sur les
bancs de l'assemblée nationale bruno le
maire s'est il fait rouler est ce la fin
d'une époque pour l'etat-actionnaire on
en parle dans un instant dans le grand
débat on parlera aussi de ce vote très
politique sur l'île vg en passant de 12
à 14 semaines le délai légal les
marcheurs à l'assemblée s'émancipe du
gouvernement qui n'était pas favorable à
cette mesure des marcheurs enfin libre
ce sera l'analyse des z'amours d'un
gamin dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission et puis françois durpaire à
regarder pour nous le débat des
candidats à la vice-présidence pour la
maison blanche
kamala harris mike pence les numéros 2
n'ont jamais été aussi importants voilà
sur tous ces sujets on va revenir avec
notre grand témoin ce soir elle est
écologiste lé cache aussi et elle publie
en plomb fléau vitriol contre la
technocratie s'appelle rendez nous la
france rien que ça c'est un titre et
c'est un programme
isabelle saporta est avec nous ce soir
voilà pour le programme tout de suite le
grand débat
[Musique]
bonsoir isabelle saporta en soit merci
d'être avec nous est notre grand témoin
ce soir ça veut dire qu'on va parler
beaucoup de sujets de l'actualité bien
sûr et de ce titre rendez nous la france
alors quel titre quand j'ai vu ça je me
suis dit mais quelle mouche l'a piqué le
sous titre en finir avec la caste qui
paralyse d'une haute tension ce que
notre pays
ouais c'est ça enfin ça fait un bon
moment d'inattention en fait je pense
que ça fait quelques années qu'on est
chez fayard le titre je le dis des
muscles et parfois il fleure un peu le
populisme et c'est plus subtil
c'est plus voilà documenté il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'expérience très
concrète et ça raconte notamment à la
faveur de votre campagne à paris les
difficultés de notre pays c'est parfois
totalement ubuesque notamment dans la
crise sanitaire on va en parler mais
d'abord l'actualité c'est cette fusion
contestée entre veolia et suez il s'agit
d'un secteur absolument stratégique
celui de l'eau ça doit forcément vous
intéressez isabelle saporta
bonsoir françois de rugy soir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député la
république en marche de loire-atlantique
ancien ministre de l'écologie et vous
débattez ce soir avec olivier marc l'ex
bonjour bonsoir à vous bienvenus député
des républicains de relais
d'eure-et-loir sébastien cochard et en
duplex de riyad en arabie saoudite
bonsoir monsieur vous êtes économiste
ancien haut fonctionnaire
ryad où vous travaillez aujourd'hui
comme banquier enfin bon soir stéphane
bonsoir meilleur ravi de vous retrouver
comme ça que soit vous avez dû bosser ce
soir pour votre billet et c'est quoi ce
sujet à la 16e parce qu'effectivement
c'est un dossier compliqué mais qui
concerne tous les français si j'ai bien
compris tout de suite
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris stéphane si j'ai
bien compris c'est quand même pas si
compliqué ce l'histoire on peut résumer
ça c'est simplement en fait veolia veut
prendre le contrôle de suez voilà reste
basse quoi c'est pas plus compliqué que
ça mais faut pas rigoler c'est une très
très bonne nouvelle parce qu'on était
déjà champion du monde de foot avec les
bleus champions du monde de cyclisme
avec julian alaphilippe si veolia prend
le contrôle de suez là on devient
champion du monde du traitement de l'eau
et des déchets ça vous fait pas rêver sa
vie de klaxonner sur les champs
remontant duroueix on avait deux
champions vous réjouissez pas trop vite
cependant parce que ce n'est pas encore
fait il ya un petit problème au gabon
alors quel est le problème
enfin rien broutilles vous allez voir
simplement que les dirigeants de ce fait
ce ne sont pas du tout d'accord mais
alors pas du tout du tout du tout
d'accord pour se faire racheter par
veolia alors justement comment en veolia
peut acheter suez
si l'entreprise au fond n'est pas à
vendre alors ça c'est la magie du
capitalisme
myriam c'est à dire que dans quel état
libre tout est à vendre en fait puisque
swayze est une société cotée en bourse
il ya des actions si on achète les
actions c'est ce que veut faire veolia
on devient propriétaire de ce fait est
donc veolia a déjà racheté 30% donc des
actions de suez et maintenant ils
annoncent qu'ils vont racheter les 70%
restants on s'appelle une au pea c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui suez bardon veolia
vous propose 18 euros pourrait acheter
une action suez alors qu'elle est côté
en fin de séance à 16 euros donc ça peut
être une incitation à vous débarrasser
de vos actions alors justement comment
veolia a réussi à acheter un tiers du
capital de suez s'ils ne voulaient pas
bon dans cette capitale
alors là encore c'est la magie du
capitalisme un circuit les dirigeants de
ce rêve ne veulent pas vendre mais c'est
pas eux les propriétaires ils sont juste
dirigeants donc sont les actionnaires
qui sont propriétaires et donc parmi les
actionnaires il avait un très important
qui dépose qui dispose d'un tiers du
capital de suez et qui s'appelle angie
vous ne connaissez peut-être ils nous
envoient un courrier régulièrement pour
vous réclamer des sous pour le gaz c'est
le petit bonhomme bleu donc ce qui s'est
passé c'est assez simple veolia a mis 3
milliards 400 millions sur la table en
disant à angie j'achèterai bien 30%
dessous est ce pour ça et angie a dit
pas d'accord oui 10 3 milliards et demi
au quai alors puisque l'état est le
principal actionnaire dmj principal ne
vante voulant pas dire majoritaire est
ce que ça veut dire qu'il était d'accord
pour vendre les
action de suez et veolia je vous ai déjà
parlé de la magie du capitalisme voilà
c'est un peu ça parce que l'état est
actionnaire principal mais pas
majoritaire donc il ya eu un vote au
moment de décider si on pouvait vendre
ou passer 30% et ce vote dans cette
aisance se voit plus tard était mis en
minorité ce qui lui a voté contre il a
dit non je ne vous ne pouvez pas vendre
ses 30% de suez mais la majorité a dû le
contraire donc hop ça a été vendu à
veolia donc forcément au nom de la mère
qui a dit non bah ils passent en
position de faiblesse il a dit je veux
pas les vendre finalement ils ont été
vendus comme c'est donc c'était il ya
une partie de la presse qu'il interprète
comme ça effectivement nous avoir
quelques articles vous allez voir le
point pense que l'état a pris une gifle
est un peu dans la même veine mais avec
un autre mot europe 1 pensent que l'état
a pris une baffe
et puis c'est pire sait plus comment
faire titre accrocheur aujourd'hui mais
en même temps c'est on peut aussi le
voir autrement en fait peut-être que
l'état n'était finalement pas si hostile
au fait que veolia rached suez
simplement
simplement il n'avait pas forcément
envie de le dire voyez parce que d'un
côté bruno vair il est content d'avoir
un champion du monde du traitement des
déchets de l'eau d'imaginer qu'à quelle
joie pour tout le monde mais simplement
le problème dans ces fusions dans ces
grosses boîtes c'est bon on fait des
économies d'échelle et seront ça conduit
à des oeufs des suppressions d'emplois
l'un dans le courant ça serait plusieurs
milliers d'emplois alors est-ce que de
renaud lemaire envie d'assumer ça en ce
moment où le chômage est à bientôt 10 %
jeu pas forcément donc lui ce qu'il
voudrait en fait c'est que son rêve de
mariage de veolia suez mais sans qu'ils
arrivent à faire sans qu'il ait à
intervenir sur 2 2 je sais pas quand
mais après c'est un mariage d'amour
infini good movie où tout se passerait
sans heurts en écoute jeux de force
je vous le dis je n'y crois pas je pense
que ça ne marche pas ça ne marche pas
dans la vie il se ne marche pas non plus
dans la vie des affaires
donc la position de l'état elle a été
constante
il faut un accord amiable entre suez et
veolia donc ce qu'on retient c'est que
on avait redit il faut un accord donc il
précise amiable mais l'adjectif on s'en
fout un peu
il faut un accord entre suez et veolia
donc l'état partisan cet accord il veut
ce mariage
il se cache un peu pour le dire mais la
question c'est de savoir est ce que
c'est une bonne idée de mariée suez
la question pour ce pour démarrer ce
débat merci pour cet état des lieux
limpide j'ai tout compris merci stéphane
alors j'ai perdu quelques neurones le
bien fondé de cette fusion françois de
rugy est ce que c'est bon au fond pour
les deux entreprises veolia et suez
c'est même bon pour les trois
entreprises parce qu'à une petite
inexactitudes dans ce qui a été dit
c'est que c'est d'abord angie qui a
voulu vendre ses parts dans suez et
pourquoi angie a voulu vendre ses parts
dans suez c'est parce que c'est une
vieille histoire
un précédent gouvernement celui de
monsieur de villepin avait voulu
fusionner de force
gdf à l'époque et suez pour en faire un
groupe qui est et qui n'avait pas de
cohérence puisque d'un côté vous avez du
gaz et de l'énergie et de l'autre côté
vous aviez le traitement de l'eau et le
traitement des déchets est depuis des
années il n'y a eu aucune synergie comme
on dit entre angie et suez et des
principales directions envisageait de
mai au contraire non pas se séparer de
souhait de racheter la totalité de la
belle coacher oui mais justement il y a
eu un changement de stratégie assez
nette
dmj qui a souhaité sortir d'un certain
nombre de participations comme ça veut
dire qu'en gros là et je m'occupais de
l'eau est ensuite il y avait au lia qui
dit moi je suis intéressé de racheter
les parts d' angie dans suez car ça
permettra de faire un grand groupe qui à
l'échelle mondiale parce que là ce dont
on parle c'est une bataille mondiale sur
les technologies de l'environnement les
technologies qui permettront demain de
mieux traiter l'eau de mieux traiter les
déchets de mieux recyclés par exemple
pour recycler cet appareil ce téléphone
portable il va falloir développer des
technologies très poussée pour extraire
les métaux rares etc tout cela ça
nécessite des efforts de recherche
il faut financer cette recherche mais
ensuite il faut l'amortir sur le marché
mondial pas simplement sur le marché
français sa clé du haut-rhinois comme on
dit dans les affaires gagnant gagnant
oui tout à fait et surtout ça fait très
longtemps que veolia et suez se sont
développées à l'étranger il faut pas
regarder cette question uniquement à
travers la situation franco-française
ces entreprises sont partis de france
pour conquérir le monde depuis très
longtemps
elles ont réussi mais en unissant leurs
forces elles pourront faire beaucoup
mieux vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse
non pas du tout d'abord je regrette
c'est vraiment la farce à laquelle ce
que joue l'état sous notre nez
pour aller plus loin plus en amont en
corse que ce que dit françois de rugy
la première décision c'est pas angie qui
décide de vendre la première décision
c'est l'état actionnaire qui décide que
angie doit vendre voilà c'est celle-là
doc c'est en réalité pour vous pour vous
cessé depuis le début la stratégie de
l'état parce que c'est pas très visible
de cette figure est même pas eu de débat
si l'état n'avait pas donné son feu vert
au moins à deux reprises d'abord quand
ils virent madame kocher pour le
remplacer par monsieur clamadieu numéro
un je le rappelle dmj que monsieur jean
pierre clamadieu au démantèlement
j ai donc on remplace même kocher par
une équipe qui est plus de cils pour
faire ce que l'état actionnaire
la nouvelle patronne d'arrivée d'annecy
c'est madame mcgregor kate catherine
mcgregor c'est pas étonnant justement
que ça se fasse dans une période certes
c'est monsieur clamadieu le le patron
mes patrons assurances et l'état
actionnaire l'état un quart du capital
de dungey il a 33 % 33 et quelques qui
lui donne la majorité minorité de
blocage de droits de vote
shinji le patron c'est l'état c'est le
président de la république et donc
premiers éléments il valide cette
stratégie de démantèlement deuxième
élément peut pas imaginer dans ce pays
que monsieur frérot patron de veolia
lance une opa sur suez boîte
indirectement détenue par l'état s'en
aller quand même
on la république n'est qu'il ait pas un
accord de monsieur macro qui connaît
très bien puisque ils ont
le premier était un supporter du second
pendant sa campagne présidentielle et
donc tout ça se fait avec le soutien des
états et puis tout d'un coup l'état
disparaît l'état se planquent plus
personne n'assume les administrateurs
sont priés de voter contre mais on
s'arrange quand même pour que le truc
pas ce dernier élément qui prouve que
que l'état tout à fait d'accord avec sa
stratégie c'est que s'ils étaient contre
il aurait demandé une assemblée générale
des actionnaires une somme générale
extraordinaire il avait une minorité de
blocage pour pourquoi est ce que l'état
n'assume pas pourquoi mais quand même il
s'agit de l'eau de l'assainissement de
la gestion de l'eau pour les français
avoir un énorme champion à la fois
nationale et internationale avec veolia
qui reprend suez si on va voir si c'est
possible ou pas récupérer 100% de suez
est ce que c'est ce que c'est bien c'est
pas gagné mais est ce que est ce que
c'est une bonne chose
on voit déjà que les maires sont très
inquiets parce qu'il se rendait compte
que déjà avec ces deux géants qui était
que son suez et veolia qui est en
position de quasi monopole et qui a fait
60 % de l'eau et de l'assainissement
d'eau il était déjà dans une position où
on avait des prix très élevé de l'eau
est d'ailleurs des prix qui parfois été
complètement irrationnel avec suez qui
ne faisait pas le même prix pour du
mètre cube dans telle est l endroit
passant du simple au double pareil pour
veolia donc on voyait qu'il y avait déjà
une énorme appréhension
cette appréhension elle est renforcée
aujourd'hui avec l'idée qui est un
monopole alors monopole c'est bien qu'on
peut dire sur les rangs c'est un
monopole puisqu'il est parti il va vous
le dire honneur mais je suis bien dans
mes bras quand rien oui alors autour de
cette table répondre rien du monopole de
l'élite et puis on propose le dans cette
action et tombent aussi des querelles
méridian moins qu'un autre chose en même
temps vie aux idées restent à bata armée
un concurrent de demain donc on voit
bien que tout ça est une tartufferie
pour éviter de détail a le monopole
faille à bruxelles et yahia
c'est plus compliqué voilà s'il vous
plaît on essaye de suivre donc
maintenant nous allons à sur le prix de
l'eau game nature le prix de l'eau il ya
une inquiétude est par ailleurs vous
savez fabien causeur sondés contre
environ sont absolument pas lié aux
détenteurs d'actions du lit maires de
france qui sont tous les pays non non
pas du tout c'est complètement faux
s'est pas vite sans l'aimer et il y en a
qui se sont exprimés contre les hôtes du
sommet total est plutôt dans la
recherche de la vérité d'aleris étaient
ceux qui nous regardent actions des
choses à la vente de suez longtemps et
comme une droite et non mais je
l'entends je dire voilà maintenant sur
la question de la régie des régies
municipales puisque ya beaucoup de
maires qui ont dit que dans ces cas-là
il reviendrait à une régie municipale on
sait aujourd'hui quand on est en régie
municipale le prix de l'eau est moindre
et que par ailleurs et l'état des
canalisations est meilleure qu'il ya
moins de fuites donc moi ce que j'espère
je vous dire c'est que les municipalités
se réarment rond et choisiront de
refaire de l'eau en fait un vrai enjeu
républicain puisque ça c'est vraiment la
vraie caisse alors quelles seront les
conséquences sociales pour ce super
grands groupes on va poser la question à
notre économiste sébastien cochard
est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous décrire
ce qui peut se passer parce qu'on entend
beaucoup d'inquiétude on a parlé du prix
de l'eau mais il ya aussi l'emploi ce
sont des énormes groupe qui emploie des
milliers de salariés
quelles garanties a obtenu l'état
finalement dans cette fusion ne connais
pas les garanties que l'état par contre
il qu'il est clair si vous lisez la
logique boursière qu'il qu'il est
derrière les opérations et qui va se
révéler ni catastrophe pour la société
fusionnée puisque là les halls ya à peu
près 10 milliards 11 milliards de tête
sur elle en a à peu près autant le coût
de rachat va représenter également des
dinars d'avoir une société fusionnée qui
va avoir plus de 30 milliards de terres
ce qui va être donc absolument dans la
capacité d'investir le moindre centime
dans le développement des technologies
du futur dont parlait de cette origine
et et 7
quand on dirait j'ai évidemment la
logique de maximisation pour
l'actionnaire va faire affaire que les
plans de les plans de coupes claires
dans les effectifs lourds être la
première chose qui va être mise en place
sur les marchés financiers là déjà à
promettre 4000 suppressions d'emplois le
plus rapidement possible je vous vois
dire non de la tête françois de rire
mais c'est quand même un prophète
inquiétude elle est légitime
on a vu d'autres groupes saab serait
alors qu'ils sont les premiers acteurs
que j'ai rencontrés dans cette histoire
ce sont les syndicalistes de suez
je les ai rencontrés ici à l'assemblée
en contre et on a discuté
qui vous dit vous n'avez pas écouté une
pseudo rougerie bas ils sont content et
ça se comprend mais ça se comprend est
ce que je vous ai dix analystes
tout à l'heure vous avez reproché aux
intérêts dans pardonnez-moi si vous
appelez super qualité votre mot anglais
tout à l'heure on vous écoute
attentivement mais fédérer ce mois je
j'ai évidemment discuter avec les
salariés de suez et c'est normal qu'ils
le demandent des garanties c'est ce
qu'il souhaitait et observer les
salariés d'une entreprise c'est pas
tellement ce qui compte pour eux c'est
pas tellement l'actionnaire c'est que
l'entreprise à laquelle ils
appartiennent est une entreprise qui va
se développer
oui ou non écoutés mais ça c'est à
projets les avait pas obtenu jeudi rien
moi on comment vous osez dire qu'on n'a
obtenu aucune garantie sont les salariés
ils se battraient d'une fusion réussie
je vais encore de 2,2 ferry de longueur
de phrases ou n'avait cessé que de dire
des idioties arthur le credo sur le brio
de bellegarde et les arts et le tableau
de comparaison des prix de l'eau en
france
elle a essayé de reprendre vous avez et
vous ressentez vous verrez qu'à ce
moment là
moi vous savez j'ai été élu vous n'avez
jamais été élu vous avez été candidate
ne nous a pas été moi j'ai été viré
rouge est mécontent d'avoir le nez
regardez moi c'est vrai que ce soit de
vous parler en même temps on les
spectateurs samedi lors d'un match de
rugby
s'il vous plaît on en est où la parole
puisque tout à l'heure vous disiez
rendez nous la chansonnette
on s'écoute je vous donne ma parole vous
mentez quand même est-ce qu'on a encore
le trader des plantes et dans le débat
public va scorer tu as le droit tweets
et des idioties allez vous vous étiez
déjà sur les dents pardonnez moi vous
interrompez pour faire maintenant allez
françois de région vous écouterez le
mépris social qu'est vraiment on
comprend pas que ça marche pas la macro
ni à les arrêter et méprisant dans un an
la progression des prix social vous êtes
on essaye d'avoir un débat constructif
sur un dossier compliqué donc on essaye
de savoir oui ou non ces salariés ont de
quoi s'inquiéter ou pas vous parler d'un
développement de l'avenir de
l'entreprise ça suffit pour éviter des
coupes dans l'emploi non la question 1
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux être salarié
d'une entreprise qui se développe ou pas
la réponse et c'est bien d'avoir une
entreprise qui a un projet industriel et
angie n'avait aucun projet industriel
pour suez suez d'ailleurs on peut très
bien également
j'ai discuté avec eux j'ai j'intervenais
dans un de leurs collègues il ya un an
et ils m'ont dit ray la parole dessus
elle assure nous nous sommes une
entreprise indépendante au sein du
groupe mgi c'était ça leur position ça
peut se défendre c'était une position
clairement capitalistique la part
d'énergie dans suez il n'y avait aucune
synergie c'est à dire aucune action
commune aucun projet commun entre angie
et suez sur les métiers de l'eau et des
déchets qui sont les deux principaux
métiers de veolia et de suez
il y a évidemment des synergies en
matière de recherche et développement
qui permettront d'amortir des coûts de
recherche important sur ces deux sujets
le traitement de l'eau ça devient de
plus en plus compliqué il ya des
nanoparticules et à la question des
antibiotiques dans l'eau etc qui
nécessitent d'être traitées champions
c'est mieux que de suez veolia a donné
des garanties sur le fait de ne
licencier personne et de garder non
seulement tous les salariés mais de
garder les conditions c'est à dire le
gros le statut et ça les salariés de
suez et de veolia sont très habitués à
cela puisque lorsqu'un contrat est passé
entre une collectivité locale et un de
ces opérateurs les salariés sont
systématiquement repris
mêmes conditions énormément
d'enseignements très protecteur des
garanties qui feront la part dont tu
sais tout leurs bidons totalement pipeau
sur les mêmes éléments de langage des
communicants à chaque fois qu'une fusion
acquisition la réalité vous mariez de
veolia 180 mille salariés dans le monde
avec suez 90 mille salariés le seul
intérêt d'une opération de ce type c'est
de récupérer le volume d'affaires des
deux réunis et de les gérer avec moins
d'effectifs donc la première décision
qui se prend dans ces cas là ces
réductions d effectifs de sièges
réduction des effectifs recherche et
développement induction des effectifs
sur leurs réseaux commerciaux je sais
pas le chiffrer les syndicats
s'inquiètent par de 5000 suppressions
d'emplois c'est probablement le seul
engagement qu'elle s'en est pris par
monsieur frérot c'est celui d'attendre
le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle qui viendra pour ne pas
créer de problèmes le reste c'est du
roman mais c'est frais c'est du même
barque on lui sert à chaque fois dans
ces grandes fusions acquisitions je me
souviens des communiqués de monsieur
macron sur alcatel nokia regardez on en
est au quatrième plan social en quatre
ans je me souviens du communiqué de
presse de monsieur macron sur alstom j
on en est on ne compte plus les plans
sociaux chez generali vite et c'est le
même les esprits en plein dans le monde
entier plus acquisitions et ses
conséquences c'est la pression sur les
effectifs et danses et de réduire les
effectifs
c'est intéressant six mois est à
l'évidence une mauvaise idée maintenant
je pense que c'est pour ça que président
de république n'assume pas cette fusion
acquisition l'homme de droite que vous
êtes les républicains et les et marne ex
est d'accord avec arnaud montebourg
qu'on va écouter tout de suite il était
l'invité de politique à table on l'a
interrogé sur cette question de v
audacieuse écouter pour moi c'est une
affaire extrêmement grave c'est un
démantèlement
d'une entreprise saine veolia n'a pas
besoin de ça pour se développer et
surtout on est plus fort quand on a deux
champions mondiaux que quand on a qu'un
donc vous allez voir les dégâts
maintenant sur le territoire sur cet
argument des deux champions françois de
rugy plutôt qu'un ce que veolia est déjà
numéro un mondial dans le traitement de
l'eau des déchets et suez numéro 2 donc
vous savez déjà ils sont déjà vides je
savais qu'elle part de marché sur
l'ensemble du marché environ 4% mais ça
reste leader 1% pour l'un d'eux d'entre
eux deux ça fait 5 donc c'est pas le
sujet de la part de marché mondiale en
revanche un vrai sujet au niveau mondial
peut-être dans ce secteur là comme dans
d'autres c'est que il y à l'émergence de
nouveaux acteurs
on n'est pas tout seul dans le monde a
requis dont vous avez les concurrents
des fonds d'investissement américain qui
essayent de racheter différents groupes
et qui peut-être d'ailleurs demain
aurait racheté suez
ça m'étonnerait pas sans que veolia s'y
intéresse et puis par ailleurs
évidemment des groupes chinois il est
tout à fait normal qu'il ait plus qu'un
seul groupe a racheté en ça ne nous rend
pas plus vulnérables que s'il y en avait
deux mon frère là ça nous permet de nous
enfin de nous battre avec même une
longueur d'avancé car aujourd'hui veolia
et suez ont un savoir faire
technologique que peu de groupes dans le
monde
on est donc c'est une force mais ce
savoir faire technologique cette avance
technologique on ne va pas la garder
éternellement
les groupes chinois ils vont évidemment
méchant que chacun puisse que le marché
chinois est énorme mais il se contente
pas du marché chinois et c'est tout à
fait normal
vous savez les usines d'incinération
d'issy les moulineaux à côté de paris
qui brûlent les ordures des parisiennes
et des parisiens est la part elle avait
été alloué un groupe espagnol qui a été
racheté par les chinois c'est ça la
réalité du monde dans lequel nous vivons
alors justement que il est tout à fait
normal et du côté de ryad puisque c'est
la mondialisation l'économie ce que vous
êtes sébastien cochard boîtier les
choses de la même manière on est plus
fort au fond avec un seul grand champion
face à la compétition mondiale
au contraire comme vous l'avez
d'ailleurs le champion qui va résulter
de la fusion de champion français actuel
va être au contraire beaucoup plus
facile à avaler par des prédateurs
d'étrangers quand il arriva logique
industrielle en réalité contrairement à
ce que dit monsieur le président
n'hésite pas à dire que ce que va faire
perdre ya c'est de vendre par
appartements les activités dessus elle
va travers le monde et encore une fois
étant donné le niveau d'endettement
colossal de la société fusionnée
le prix de l'action va baisser
progressivement elle va devenir une fois
de plus en plus facile pour justement
les fonds sont réalisables et uniquement
techniquement l'étranger ont battu les
américains les américains j'aime citer
ces chiffres tiennent enfin les députés
américains les actions américaines
représentent à peu près presque 60 % de
l'ensemble des actions mondiales il
continue à en créer en permanence donc
ils créent la monnaie qu'il voulait
qu'ils leur faire acheter absolument
tout ce qui est lié leur monde et tout
ce qui leur semble adéquat des proies
comment il agit à la fois facile et
rentable la société fusionnée être
évidemment la proie de d'action
d'opérations hostiles dr no mercy bon un
tableau plutôt sombre
si vous êtes un peu en minorité trois
autres usines alors je me faire l'avocat
du diable et on le solde a rugi est un
bon soldat
mais il défend main publiquement ce que
le gouvernement n'en fait pas d'efforts
là vous savez j'ai 6 1 points en top
j'étais d'accord avec vous c'est qu'au
départ le l'initiative n'a pas pu être
lancée puisque en effet vous avez
aujourd'hui que vous avez un appel
d'offres quelque part dans le monde vous
avez deux entreprises françaises qui
répondent le numéro à l'autre numéro 2
de bain il y aura plus qu'une entreprise
française qui répondra donc c'est
l'effet sur l'accueil que vous voyez
déjà le premier réflexe cette fusion est
assez et a cédé au fait que ce soit un
monopole parce que si cette fusion
aboutisse géant
oui mais avoir des conséquences au
niveau de 2 kw à 2
l'eau en france parce qu'elles ont
décodé mode saas européen de la
concurrence on va voir jusqu'où va
s'appliquer le droit de la concurrence
on sait que veolia a dit je vais
revendre le au dos de suez en france
mais il ya la même question sur les
déchets la concurrence d'avoir un seul
champion national monopolistique sur ce
marché pour bien comprendre mais c'est
parce que portal a dit très justement
pas souhaitable d'avoir évidemment
on a besoin de concurrence son marché
français puisque délais des français
payent le service de l'eau et des
services des déchets et donc on a besoin
de concurrence sur le marché français
sur le marché la concurrence et donc il
aura même bien la concurrence et donc
elle va avoir des exigences
assez assez forte autorité de la
concurrence en france aussi sur l'eau
sur les déchets sur le déchet en france
mais aussi dans d'autres pays européens
la question va se poser
donc on sait pas au bout du compte ce
qui va vraiment rester dessus
aujourd'hui ça je crois que c'est
inquiétant il en a pas beaucoup de gars
si ce n'est qu'on a choisi la famille de
monsieur macron par hasard le patron de
meridian qui est l'heureux élu
mais qui se fera sans doute aidé par des
entreprises américaines
sachant que son situation de monopole
dit je viens avec un partenaire et un
fonds qui n'a pas du tout l'habitude de
gérer un réseau de concession d'eau mais
il est l'heureuse élue parce qu'il est
pour d'autres des raisons qui nous
échappent un peu enfin que je viens de
que je viens de dessiner et et qui a
fait dire à arnaud montebourg
effectivement qu'on sent une sorte de
distribution de privilèges quelques amis
oligarques et qui est d'ailleurs qui n'a
pas les moyens de racheter un petit fond
cas pas des moindres car des 3 milliards
donc il sera sans doute aidé par des
entreprises publiques par des banques
publiques pour arriver à cette opération
kato désormais les odeurs monsieur
macron et qui sont sept mais moi je vois
juste rectifier une chose c'est que le
fond meridiam puisque c'est comme ça
qu'ils s'appellent il est très habitué à
investir pour la longue durée c'est sa
stratégie ses investissements à 25 ans
n'ont en effet jusqu'à présent pas dans
des radios nommé dans des concessions
d'infrastructures routières ornières et
des services type hôpitaux aéroports
donc investir dans un français les
réseaux d'eau j'aimerais d'être lié dans
la durée avec d'un investisseur qui ne
devrait pas connaître très bien le
métier de l'eau donc ça je comprends que
vous ne l'ayez pas entendu mais il ya vu
que le gens qui sont très inquiets par
ailleurs je re juste finale et une faute
sur angie puisque mjd qui est devant
pour se recentrer sur son coeur de
métier
quand isabelle kocher qui a été débarqué
de façon assez dégueulasse
de deyne j en disant que c'était parce
que c'était une femme quand même qu'elle
n'était pas à la hauteur c'est surtout
qu'elles investissent énormément dans
les énergies renouvelables
si la lettre a raison et que en plus
angie va investir massivement à hauteur
de plusieurs milliards dans des sables
bitumineux dégueulasse je vous dirais
que franchement c'est le bout du bout de
cet investissement d'aujourd'hui que je
ne trouve pas tout à fait à la hauteur
et qu'elle est donc quel est votre
source excusez moi je ne sais pas écouté
disais allez on va aller sur eux mais le
dit quoi justement y laissa déborder le
choix store des génies ce serait
justement sur la production d'énergie le
renouvelables et le gaz coûte est ce pas
parce que tu as donné mois par la
commission nous avons auditionné sur
d'origine c'est pas parceque vous
parlerai plus fort que moi et que vous
couvrir est ma voix que vous empêcherait
de parler non mais comme depuis le début
c'est ce que vous faites et vous êtes
une agressivité qui n'a pas de limite en
effet de jeu on effeuille de ramener un
même avéré n'étaient sur ce plateau s'il
vous plaît on va parler de bruno le
maire parce que en fait ce qui est
étonnant c'est que si comme vous le
dites depuis le début en tout cas de ce
côté de ce plateau mais il souhaitait
fusion pour voir bruno le maire au fond
a demandé ce mariage à l'amiable
pourquoi bruno le maire a tout fait pour
obtenir des conditions quand on écoute
les députés certes pas dans la majorité
il estime au fond qu aucun chef de
gouvernement aurait pu accepter ça
valérie rabault c'était hier lors des
questions au gouvernement écouter pensez
vous que quiconque aurait osé faire
subir une telle humiliation général de
gaulle à georges pompidou à françois
mitterrand avec ce conseil
d'administration c'est l'état qui a été
humiliée et donc nous toutes et tous
est ce qu'on peut parler d'humiliation
françois de rugy pour l'etat-actionnaire
madame rabot et dans une opposition
toujours plus radicale et l'oubli il ya
eu des raids boursiers sous la
présidence de françois mitterrand sous
tous les présidents il ya des affaires
qui se font et des entreprises qui se
marient d'autres qui parfois divorce
c'est la vie des affaires sur angie
veolia suez
bruno le maire a dit je préférerais
qu'ils s'entendent
évidemment tout le monde préférerait que
ce soit
riach qui soit fait dans la bonne
entente mais vous savez très bien que
dans les affaires je dansais la
différence est qu'il a eu raison bruno
le maire d'essayer de se battre en
pleine crise sanitaire pour obtenir ce
mariage à l'amiable
c'est pas battre ou une chose il a
exercé il a exprimé une position au nom
du gouvernement tant que mise l'économie
qui était tout à fait d'ailleurs
légitime tout à fait souhaitable mais à
un moment donné quand tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord il y avait trois
acteurs y'en avait deux qui étaient
d'accord il faisait très d'accord c'est
le cas c'est le cas dans beaucoup
d'autres entreprises l'état est
actionnaire principal c'est le cas à air
france
c'est le cas la sncf c'est le cas
renault
à chaque fois c'est l'état actionnaire
qu'il est jeune et d'obéir image globale
il faut encore y fait l'équipe de l'onu
de son budget en direction nord est et l
affaire était plié il n'y avait pas de
fuite c'est une première à présenter non
c'est pas une humiliation du tout fait
c'est une humiliation à poser peut-être
pas le président de la république a
soumises de l'économie on a préféré
faire jouer à bruno le maire le rôle de
l'idiot utile pardon en se faisant
battre on a préféré passer l'état
préfère passer pour faibles plutôt que
d'assumer les conséquences économiques
sociales de cette fusion de cet opéra
qui la remet à dénis qui l'a béni sans
doute à une autre époque et d'authie n'a
pas le courage de dire qu'aujourd'hui
elle est mal venu ces concepts l'enquète
de mediapart qui vous l'avez vue
explique que les conseils
d'administration ne sont pas ceux que
l'on croyait martine orange à mediapart
dit que le secrétaire-général de la
république a demandé fait pression sur
la cfdt pour que les types de la cfdt
sorte de opportunément de la seule se
passe c'est vrai ou pas si c'est vrai
c'est évidemment extrêmement grave
et de toute façon ce qui accrédite que
même cette thèse c'est une fois encore
que l'état va en réalité vous n'avez
qu'à demander une assemblée générale des
actionnaires pour bloquer l'opération si
réellement il était contre tout ça c'est
une espèce de théâtre je sais pas quel
rôle rejoue ce pauvre bruno le maire
dans cette affaire effectivement c'est
pas glorieux pour lui mais le vrai
problème c'est pourquoi est ce que
monsieur macron n'assume pas cette opr
l'avais dit je voudrais élargir ce débat
vous ne serez pas d'accord sur cette
fusion c'est sûr est ce que c'est la fin
d'une époque pour les critères
actionnaires est ce que il faut se
réjouir finalement que c'est la loi du
capitalisme comme vous le dites
seul
l'actionnaire le plus fort majoritaire
peut décider alors que ça n'était pas le
cas dans la vie des affaires dont les
entreprises où l'état étaient présents
jusqu'à présent il ya deux choses ya la
question de fond en parle pas beaucoup
c'est dommage mais enfin quand même
c'est un projet industriel de fonds
après on peut se perdre dans des idées
des arguties comme si mediapart était
dans le bureau d'à lexicaux l'heure où
vous piraté son téléphone enfin c'est
n'importe quoi
alors on a vu un truc de fou a cédé leur
céder leur envoie des leurs pour pas
parler du fond pour toi de régis
extrêmes où la terre on paie donc chacun
peut s'écouter à gré vous dorer la
parole après non pas du tout enfin
d'origine répondait c'est complet et sur
le soleil tout à fait raison de poser
aussi la question du rôle de l'état
actionnaire
moi je fais partie de ce depuis très
longtemps qui pensent que ce n'est pas
très utile que l'état soit un
actionnaire minoritaire dans des
entreprises
sauf quand ça sert à stabiliser une
situation on l'a vu dans le précédent
mandat l'état a pris des parts dans
peugeot psa en ce qui n'était jamais
arrivé auparavant cette entreprise 100%
privé pour faire un accord d'ailleurs
avec un industriel chinois et ça a
permis à un moment donné de stabiliser
la situation pour que peugeot se
redéveloppe ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui et sans doute que la
vocation c'est ensuite de se retirer
en revanche il ya des entreprises dans
lesquelles on est moi je préférais voyez
vous que l'on se pose la question de
pourquoi quand l'état est majoritaire
voire à 100 % de réussite et la sncf edf
c'est 84%
ce n'est pas l'état qui dirige davantage
oui vous c'est pas plus la volonté
politique qui s'exprime et c'est plus la
technostructure interne et là peut être
que nous pourrions nous rejoindre je
n'ai pas encore lu les mecs la
technostructure interne de ces
entreprises qui sont d état dans l'état
qui gouvernent plutôt que l'état
pour françois de rugy je m'inquiète de
l'emprise mentale quand même dans le
schéma cran est capable sur les membres
de sa majorité parce que je me suis
incapable ya un débat soutenu par le ps
je suis un défenseur
je pense que dans des dents des grands
infrastructures d'intérêt vital
stratégique pour le pro la nation on a
besoin que l'état joue son rôle il n'y
aurait plus air france depuis des années
depuis des dizaines d'années peut-être
si l'état n'avait pas été actionnaire il
aurait plus peugeot celle de l'app est
actionnaire alstom a été selon en 2004
très récent on a besoin d'action et
d'ailleurs donc dans tous les états
libéraux libéraux chance faiblesse de la
fiscalité
je pense notamment aux pays bas il ya un
et actionnaires qui qui s'assume
regardez quand on a voulu privatiser adp
immédiatement les hollandais sont montés
au capital d'air france klm pour nous
donner une bonne le champ une idée au
passage
attention c'est là notre compagnie comme
lui ne vous ferai pas n'importe quoi je
rends forte imposition et doyer certains
secteurs stratégiques une attraction
merci on va s'arrêter là beaucoup
d'arguments été changé c'était
passionnant et passionné et passionnant
merci à vous et isabelle saporta vous
restez avec nous on va parler un petit
peu de vous et on va parler de de ce
livre une écolo en guerre contre les
techno c'est parti merci à vous merci
[Musique]
alors quelles charges je le disais
qu'elle charge isabelle saporta contre
la technostructure vous dénoncer les
aberrations de la bureaucratie les
milliers voire des centaines de milliers
de normes absurde qui paralyse
dites-vous le pays une caste qui rend
notre pays
invivable c'est à ce point là ben oui
écoutez c'est vrai que quand on se
plonge un petit peu dans les méandres de
comment fonctionne la technostructure
française on se rend compte que on a sur
le terrain
beaucoup de français d'ailleurs qui qui
qui sont là qui vous écoute qui nous
écoutent et qui ont des idées
incroyables pour essayer développer la
france et qui jamais ne rentrer dans les
cases jamais et en fait c'est vrai que
on s'est rendu compte si vous voulez au
moment du coc vide que qui a fonctionné
une comme une espèce de loupe sur l'état
de la france que on n'avait aucun sens
pratique si vous voulez on avait une
administration qui réquisitionnait les
minces que pendant que l'autre les
brûler parce qu'ils étaient prétendument
comment d'hier est l'exemple que vous
que vous donnez l'état également vitesse
mais elle était son pourrez vous savez
je pourrais faire un tome 2 parce que
les tests aujourd'hui c'est un peu la
même chose on a vu qu'on avait été
incapable de demander aux laboratoires
vétérinaires de nous aider parce qu'on
avait édicté une loi en 2013 qui disait
que quand on faisait du laboratoire
humain on ne faisait pas du laboratoire
vétérinaire
là encore jusqu en août dernier on ne
s'est pas servi des laboratoires
vétérinaires c'est c'est vrai que ça n'a
aucun sens si vous voulez on a
l'impression qu'on te on ne va jamais
vers les forces vives et par contre on
édicte des règlements des cahiers des
charges hyper strict dans lesquelles
vous savez si le problème ne rentrent
jamais je sais pas ce que ça vous fait
vous quand vous recevez un papier mais
généralement rentre jamais dans les
quinze noms des morts pendant la crise
sanitaire puisque vous dites tout se
décide de dents au bar des hauts
fonctionnaires que vous appelez des cost
killers il ya eu aussi beaucoup de
flexibilité dans les hôpitaux par
exemple beaucoup de d'agilité hutu lyon
2-0 déployés mais grâce à qui grâce
justement à ces gens qui sont sur le
terrain ces médecins ces aides soignants
et infirmiers
ça fait un an qu'ils étaient dans la rue
rappelez-vous le mouvement des
urgentistes le mouvement des médecins
qui disait arrêtés nous assommer sous la
paperasserie arrêté on en peut puis
jetée même leur blues vous vous souvenez
ce qu'ils on pouvait plus d'être
enseveli sous la paperasse et malgré
tout ça malgré le fait que ces gens là
soient mal payés parce que c'est vrai
que tous nos sentinelle les profs les
policiers l'armée les médecins on ne les
paye pas suffisamment ils travaillent
dans des locaux l'épreuve parce que ce
livre c'est d'abord une défense du
service public qui devrait fonctionner
encore mieux qu'il ne fonctionne
aujourd'hui et malgré tout ça ils ont
endossé le rôle de sur le terrain ils y
sont allés oui quand j'entends monsieur
d'origine il est plus là pour se
défendre mais tout à l'heure et se
défendent et très bien tout seul donc je
pense que voilà on a été aujourd'hui
dans toute cette technostructure dans
une volonté effectivement de cost
killing c'est à dire que non seulement
eux ne se l'appliquent pas eux-mêmes
jamais mais effectivement chaque jour il
explique que la les services publics
français coûte un pognon dingue mais ce
qui coûte un pognon dingue c'est pas les
médecins c'est pas les profs c'est pas
les gens qui sont sur le terrain c'est
tout ses métastases bureaucratique qu'on
ne cesse d'empiler à chaque fois et lors
celle là alors là on n'y touche jamais
voyez il ya toujours et a toujours une
liste avec complaisance
vous vous diriez que ce gouvernement n'a
absolument rien fait le précédent aussi
ça fait des années qu'il ya des loi sur
la simplification administrative
arrêtez d'emmerder les français emmanuel
macron lui-même kilani a senti bien pied
sûr que vous le disiez parce que j'ai eu
droit à toute la macro ni à peu près
aussi condescendance que monsieur rhji
qu'ils m'expliquent oui votre livre est
publié sous est livrée complète esata
tatatata c'était un problème de mât cros
a lui même parlé la caste parler de lens
reçoit disait qu'il fallait en finir
avec le pouvoir de la technostructure
retrouver le pouvoir politique
et qu'est ce qu'on voit en fait avec la
macro ni c'est que au contraire le
pouvoir politique n'a jamais été aussi
faible enfin la mascarade que vous nous
donnez nous décrire avec veolia c'est
vraiment un pouvoir politique
extrêmement faible et une
technostructure hyper forte et moi je
trouve que c'est très dangereux
démocratiquement parce qu'on se retrouve
dans des on se retrouve dans des choses
voyez sur le coaching sur veolia surtout
ça moi je parle aussi beaucoup dans mon
livre de tout ce qu'on a bradé comme
bijoux la de la république c'est à dire
notamment par exemple les privatisations
qu'on a fait sur les autoroutes on se
rend compte qu'on les a vendu pour une
bouchée de pain avec elle rapporte des
dividendes
vous serrez la haute administration qui
dévore au fond les politiques où ce sont
les mêmes pour vous non les élus ceux
qui nous gouvernent parce qu'ils sont
légitimement élus sont ils au fond aux
mains d'une administration qui
chercheraient la rentabilité à tout prix
ou au contraire voilà c'est les ordres
viennent du politique même moi je crois
que c'est ce que ce discours là
effectivement emmanuel macron le tient
d'une certaine façon pas avec les mêmes
mots mais aussi mémé oui le problème
c'est qu'ils n'en tire pas les
conséquences alors peut-être que c'est
très compliqué une fois que vous êtes
aux manettes ça je l'entends 1
mais si vous voulez je vois bien que le
pouvoir politique il a subi deux choses
il a subi c'était peut-être une bonne
idée l'idée de hollande du non cumul des
mandats mais en disant qu'ils avaient
des baronnies locales
mais il se trouve qu'on n'en finissant
avec le cumul des mandats on a au fond
des députés un petit peu nénuphars qui
n'ont plus leur ancrage local
ça c'est très clair on a avec le
quinquennat réduit le temps des
politiques et on a au fond une papauté
qu'est la technostructure qui dit mais
fait que vous voulez cours petit lapin
blanc
mais moi je serai toujours en place
quand toi tu seras entre guillemets mort
tu seras partie et on a vu vous rappelez
vous au coeur de l'été quand on a vu
sortir un personnage que vous et moi
enfin vous vous connaissiez peut-être
parce que vous êtes vous connaissez ça
par coeur mais qu'au fond le commun des
mortels ne connaissais pas qui était
marc guillaume le secrétaire général du
gouvernement dont tu apprends qu il est
nommé sous island qu'il continue sous
mac rang et qu'au fond cet homme avait
quasiment le droit de vie et de mort sur
le coup la région par être remercié il
faut le dire et comme en éclats les
madame ainkawa il est remercié alors
qu'il a fauté en devenant préfet d'île
de france
est-ce que vous décidez demain vous
favier débine erreur je serais tout
simplement licenciés suite se voit notre
coin et drôle isabelle saporta parce que
vous ne considérez ce discours il n'est
pas nouveau d'autres l'ont tenu sur
avant vous écoutez la bureaucratie c'est
la conviction que l'état peut et doit
tout faire
la bureaucratie c'est la conviction que
la main de l'administration est toujours
préférable à la main du citoyen qu'une
circulaire est toujours plus utile
qu'une initiative privée c'est cette
étatisme qui a gonflé l'action publique
depuis 30 ans et à mesure qu'il a
accumulé les échecs
l'état a dû promettre plus étendre
encore le domaine de ses actions il a
voulu s'occuper de tout avoir un regard
surtout plus l'état promet plus l'état
se disperse plus il déçoit
aujourd'hui dans tous les pays en europe
montrent des puissances politiques qui
viennent dire cette europe c'est la
nôtre nous souhaitons qu'elle reste la
nôtre et nous ne voulons plus nous
soumettre au diktat des technocrates
gris et froid qui ne sont pas élus alors
ce que le pays a mis des années à
construire il le détruise avec leurs
certitudes de technocrates sans cervelle
en définitive lorsque l'on ne
réfléchisse pas beaucoup voilà ce
discours sur le bon sens sur les élites
déconnectées
il est tenu à droite il est tenu à
l'extrême droite il est tenu à l'extrême
rouge mais pas par la gauche pourquoi à
votre avis écoutez je sais pas moi je
vois bien d'ailleurs que ce livret jeune
à gauche et que j'ai eu une partie de la
gauche qui me dit mais non tu ne peux
pas dire ça ils sont d'accord entre
guillemets un de façon officieuse mais
officiellement il ne faut pas le dire et
je comprends pas parce qu'ils disent et
populisme et moi je crois pas que ce
soit copié le mot de kft quand même aux
populaires mimicry ya des mots ce qu'est
ce qu'on veut au système par exemple il
a été employé depuis longtemps dans une
histoire particulière alors mais si vous
voulez alors qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
mieux c'est à dire que je donne des noms
que je vais dénonce untel untel à untel
moi j'ai pas envie de faire du de la
dénonciation de la délation parce qu'en
fait je pense pas que il sait personne
individuellement soit responsable
le premier c'est que c'est vrai que
c'est un système si un système regarder
man madame de montchanin
amélie et montchanin a dit il va falloir
qu'on réforme de fond en comble la est
comment dire les concours d'état parce
que je me rends compte qu'il ya un an tu
reçois qu'il ya elle même dit une caste
et qu'il faut absolument à faire en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas qu'un pourcent
de fils d'ouvriers qui se retrouvent à
l'ena donc si vous voulez le truc c'est
je vous dis pas qu'il le fasse exprès
dans un bon grand complot pour dominer
la versys tous c'est aussi voué aux
nouvelles ceintures ça vous êtes
journaliste vous avez fait sciences po
paris vous appartenez à ce système d'une
façon qui vous dénoncez moi au moins
j'ai les pieds sur terre et j'ai
effectivement sillonner la france dans
tous les sens que je pense qu'il
faudrait que la macro n'y fasse un petit
peu davantage pour essayer d'écouter de
comprendre cette campagne municipale que
j'ai menées effectivement avec un score
qui n'était pas extraordinaire mais deux
choses dont je suis très fier de l'avoir
mené m'a permis de rencontrer énormément
d'acteurs de terrain et des artisans des
commerçants des éboueurs des gens qui
étaient sur le pont du soir au matin et
qui avait des idées incroyables et qui
n'étaient jamais écouté et si vous
voulez au fond c'est ça c'est à dire que
la question c'est au fond est ce qu'on
arrive à un moment à écouter toutes ces
personnes qui ont des idées formidables
est ce qu'on est capable de repenser cet
état c'est à dire que regarder redonner
ce pouvoir la technostructure aux élus
aux terrains bien sûr au regard des
caisses qui a fonctionné pendant le coc
vide si qui a fonctionné c'est l'échelle
de la région
c'est l'échelle des grandes villes voilà
on a vu on a dit vraiment il faudrait un
choc pour qu'enfin on va voir si ce
discours pour plus de décentralisation
est entendu en page et une dernière
petite question puis ensuite on passe à
la séquence suivante je crois tiquement
tu viens je vous le dit un monsieur vous
vous situez parce qu'on a du mal à vous
autant comme journaliste que vous êtes
toujours dans l'âme n'y a pas de sujet
là dessus vous avez fait nombreuses
enquêtes notamment en matière
d'agriculture mais politiquement on vous
a vu aux côtés de gaspard gander à paris
puis de cédric villani toujours dans la
campagne municipale
vous collaborez comme motrices
aujourd'hui elle a revu de michel onfray
dans le front populaire n'en fait pas
partie de saison je suis pas partie de
ces auteurs
je trouve qu'on ferait fait des choses
qui étaient très peu de points et
pugnacais et il a eu raison sur beaucoup
de choses
est ce que vous cherchez un pas aux
valides septembre article 7 de cette
revue non c'est pas du tout la question
je pense qu'il faut aujourd'hui être
capable d'avoir une écologie populaire
et moi si vous voulez quand vous vous
rappelez mon parcours sur les
municipales j'ai toujours défendu une
seule chose est d'ailleurs j'étais venu
chez vous pour la défendre
c'était la coalition climat s'était
habillé de dire au fond qu'on soit
capable de la france est soumise jusqu'à
villani gaspard gander de se battre pour
une seule chose celle qui devrait être
est vrai pas de nous anime et c'est à
dire de se battre pour le climat c'est à
dire de ne pas penser pour la
récupération de son strapontin mais de
penser plus loin que nous je m'en
souviens c'est tout à fait juste on va
continuer à parler d'écologie vous allez
le comprendre pourquoi c'est l'heure de
ma journée à l'assemblée avec thomas des
prêts ou soir thomas insu elle est là
vous avez passé votre journée à parler
écologie avec des députés de droite
racontez nous oui avec les républicains
à 18 mois de l'élection présidentielle
et après le bon score des écolos aux
municipales la droite se met au vert ça
se passait ce matin dans la salle des
fêtes de l'assemblée on était avec
soraya là où ici et clément perreault
l'est républicain organisé leur rentrée
parlementaire
il y avait des députés des sénateurs des
députés européens et un invité surprise
jean louis borloo l'ancien ministre de
l'écologie de nicolas sarkozy à
l'origine du grenelle de l'environnement
il est venu leur confier sa vision de
l'écologie
à droite c'est un peu leur géant vert ou
bien faire un cours d'écologie aux
républicains bon alors officiellement
c'était pas un court mais ça y
ressemblait beaucoup jean louis borloo a
parlé pendant 15 minutes et il avait un
message précis l'écologie est de droite
nous nous sommes fait faire les poches
la réalité jacques chirac 15 en avance
le disque up de johannesburg
le grenelle de l'environnement le
grenelle de la mer c'est sale et les
faits marquants cologie de droite donc
mais il avait aussi un autre message
un avertissement aux leaders de la
droite sur les élections présidentielles
les français choisiront la meilleure
équipe c'est à dire celle qui combinera
dans une économie de marché une
croissance déterminer le retour de la
souveraineté et le retour du pacte
républicain de la région sociale
la souveraineté la république tout ça ça
pourrait être un programme de gauche
n'ont pas exactement myriam comme comme
vous quand j'ai entendu jean louis
borloo je me suis dit c'est un discours
qu'aurait pu tenir olivier faure ou à
yannick jadot
du coup j'ai demandé aux députés ce
qu'ils ont pensé vous n'avez pas peur
quand vous emparant de ce sujet de
l'écologie on dise que la droite est
devenue une gauche au nom savez ce soit
des caricatures il ya deux modèles
d'écologie à l'écologie de gauche qui
scelle punitive de la sanction du malus
il ya celle de droite que celle du bonus
de l'incitation et d'écologie positif
pragmatique au plus près des territoires
le gie de droite et une écologie de
gauche deux visions différentes selon
damien abad
mais est ce que les députés se
retrouvent vraiment on leur a fait
passer un petit est ce qu on a mélangé
des citations de jean louis borloo et de
yannick jadot 7 à 10 quand l'écologie et
dépolitisée elle fait entre 12 et 20 %
des voix jean-louis borloo ou yannick
jadot
yannick jadot c'est peut-être je dirais
yannick jadot et jean louis borloo qui a
dit ça qui a dit ian kennedy était là au
lieu de lancer la conquête de la lune il
lancerait la conquête respectueuse de la
mer et des océans
jean louis borloo ou yannick jadot ya
jadot je dirais borloo c'est jean louis
borloo qui a dit le temps des
écologistes est venu yannick jadot ou
jean louis borloo je veux essayer
negredo cadix un différend que ça
finalement
mais ça prouve que l'écologie n'est ni
de droite ni de gauche
je pense que c'est la démonstration
parfaite bon faudrait savoir que
maximino et damien abad se met peut-être
d'accord alors avant de quitter l'est
républicain ce matin on a quand même
voulu revenir avec eux sur une
déclaration qui nous avait
particulièrement marqué c'était en
décembre 2019 un député l'est
républicain dans l'hémicycle avait
clairement remis en cause la question du
réchauffement climatique
merci ceux qui travaillent n'en peuvent
plus de la multitude de normes édictées
au nom du développement durable et du
prétendu réchauffement climatique
prétendu réchauffement climatique c'est
une parole qui ne seraient plus
autorisés aujourd'hui dans votre camp un
très clairement c'est une parole que
nous partageons pas et qui n'est plus
partagée aujourd'hui notre camp donc on
ferait tout pour plus qu aucun député ne
dise une chose pareille oui une liberté
de chacun mais en tout cas compter sur
moi en tant que président de groupe pour
recadrer les choses
si tel était à nouveau le cas voilà may
hamm le message est passé et c'est 2018
c'est ce qu'il a dit ça en décembre 2019
juste avant ça fait pas longtemps
un petit mot votre commentaire on n'est
pas encore à droite ou au fond ils ont
raison fait députés elle appartient à
personne l'écologie moi j'ai enfin
plusieurs choses borloo il faut quand
même reconnaître c'est lui le grenelle
de l'environnement c'était un mec
formidable
jean louis borloo alors qu'ils soient de
droite de gauche moi la question importe
peu mais de fait il a fait des avancées
avec le grenelle que peu d'autres ont
fait après moi de toute façon je pense
que l'écologie doit devenir un sujet
central
et si vous voulez que ce soit un sujet
central est que ça devienne une matrice
pour accéder au pouvoir
il va falloir hersoy la voirie voilà
s'il peut garder drogba me paraît être
la base ouais bon suarez amont à gaza
bonsoir à rester à l'assemblée avec vous
tout de suite mais j'accueille avec
plaisir françois durpaire parce qu'il va
nous emmener du côté de salt lake city
on en reparle dans un instant elsa vous
allez vous raconter comment la majorité
a tordu le bras en quelque sorte
du gouvernement sur la question d'olive
et g oui ils sont encore en train d'en
parler dans l'hémicycle en ce moment
même où on va rembobinez un peu
l'histoire c'était la semaine dernière
en commission les députés examinent une
proposition de loi celle du groupe eds
écologie démocratie et solidarité
c'est un groupe d'anciens marcheurs un
peu déçu il propose d'allonger les
délais pour liv et gels interruption
volontaire de grossesse de douze à
quatorze semaines les députés de la
majorité vote pour jusque là pas de
problème sauf que l'exécutif est contre
sur la forme on ne touche pas à des
délais d'avortement sur une proposition
de loi qui plus est qui vient d'un
groupe d'opposition
et puis sur le fond on rappelle que
certains gynécologues sont contre cette
proposition
autre argument le conseil consultatif
national d'éthique n'a pas été saisi il
ya beaucoup de pères j'y verse à sion ce
week-end les ministres sont très
embarrassé quand on leur demande leur
choix l'exécutif
il a trois options dans l'hémicycle il
peut donner un avis favorable
suivent sa majorité défavorable au
risque de se faire désavouer ou donner
un avis de sagesse c'est un peu le en
même temps ici à l'assemblée on n'est ni
pour ni contre fond vous laisse décider
écouté le verdict ce matin donnée par le
ministre de la santé olivier veron ne
m'apparaît donc pas aujourd'hui possible
de considérer que l'orientation
principale de ce texte résoudra a en
tout cas à lui seul l'accès à diverger
c'est donc avec une sagesse hautement
mesurées sur des raisons formelles mais
qui sont significatives et auxquelles je
crois que le gouvernement abordera
chacune des questions soulevées par les
articles et les amendements invite
sagesse mais on comprend la très grande
réserve du gouvernement mais pas au
point d'émettre un avis défavorable
pourquoi est belle parce qu'en face il
ya des députés de la majorité organisé
qu'on fait savoir très vite qu'ils
adopteraient la proposition bois ils ont
mis le gouvernement au pied du mur ces
députés convaincu on va les écouter
marie-pierre axa par exemple la
présidente de la délégation aux droits
des femmes
concernant l'éthique
je note en effet que le gouvernement a
saisi le ccn
je note néanmoins que cette question de
droit de morale d'éthique a été mes
chers collègues tranché en 1974
aujourd'hui lives et jenny pas d'une
question d'éthique
c'est une question de droits des femmes
et il s'agit bien donc de faire en sorte
que ce droit ne soit plus d'un droit
totémique mais un droit réel qui se
concrétise dans la vie des femmes voilà
il va y avoir donc ce vote très
politique sur l'île vg contre plutôt
l'avis du gouvernement on l'a compris il
a un sens politique parce qu'il
intervient dans une séquence
particulière
exactement ce vote clairement ils votent
pour les députés la république en marche
en sachant que le gouvernement est
contre et puis il ya eu mardi un autre
vote celui sur la réintroduction des
néonicotinoïdes 30 de vote contre 36
abstentions chez la république en marche
c'est tout simplement un record c'était
un vote sensible où beaucoup de députés
avaient fait le parallèle avec le
glyphosate et on voit on s'attendait à
une dizaine de députés pour voter contre
et ben y en a eu 60 60 députés qui
finalement donc pas écouté le
gouvernement alors libéré délivrer les
marcheurs ou pas alors ils sont pas tout
à fait frondeurs myriam faut pas
exagérer mais on sent effectivement une
envie dans le groupe d'affirmer des
positions notamment sur des questions
sociétales et surtout de faire la
politique ne put se faire piéger par des
textes se faire traiter de tueur
d'abeilles d'un côté de conservatiste de
l'autre ces députés ils ont à leur tête
à leur tête depuis peu christophe
castaner a on le sait il a été mal élu
on le sait ya beaucoup de députés qui
réclamaient plus d'autonomie
alors christophe castaner c'est un très
proche du président il va pas aller au
clash
mais il va peut-être chorégraphié un
petit peu quelques bras de fer comme ça
entre la majorité et l'exécutif
et voilà ils sont peut-être plus
godillots nos députés marcheurs tout
arrive merci est là où passent au
décryptage qui nous emmène outre
atlantique tout de suite
[Musique]
alors vous êtes coucher très tard me
semble-t-il franchement cherché à
coucher vous allez nous parler de ce
débat des numéros 2 sur le ticket oui
kamala harris mike pence
que faut-il en généralement 10 numéros
deux là ce serait plutôt un bis parce
que les uns sont pas très en forme à 80
cents et 85 ans quand ils quitteront la
temps qu'on dit souvent linux est à un
battement de coeur de la maison blanche
presse quoi alors ceux qui aiment les
insultes ceux qui aiment les
interruptions se bat vont être déçus a
tal ben oui regardez
[Musique]
après oui ces regards langoureux
peut-être partir en vacances ensemble
mais alors là le problème c'est qu'à mme
alarie s'allier à cru à cette histoire
est en fait et en fait il est très malin
my peines et ça s'est très mal terminé
pour elle regarde et déjà c'est là où
tout bascule
si les professionnels de la santé
publique si le docteur faut aussi si les
médecins nous disent que nous devrions
le prendre eh bien je serai la première
à le prendre absolument
mais si donald trump nous dit que nous
devrions le prendre je me le prendrais
en fait vous continuer à semer le doute
dans l'esprit des gens sur la fiabilité
du vaccin
si on trouve un vaccin sous la
présidence trump je pense que ce n'est
pas raisonnable de ne pas le prendre
je vous demande juste madame la
sénatrice d'arrêter de faire de la
politique avec la vie des gens
alors ça c'est un peu coquin parce que
normalement elle était fini à séquencer
thème 15 minutes et cammalleri salle
avait fait sa formule lui il aurait pas
dû enchaîner et il a triché et avait
donné un tram c'est le cancre lui c'est
un peu le bon élève tricheurs donc et ça
a été tout le temps comme ça tout le
temps comme ça si bien que il a plutôt
dominé aux points maintenant alors on va
dire dix étaient respectueux certains
vont dire c'était ennuyeux
eux et vont regretter un peu donald
trump certains dit donald trump il est
indécent d'hôtes il est passionnant en
tout cas peut-être une petite réponse
c'est que la star la star c'était une
mouche
on va l'avoir oui la mouche logiquement
la sur les solides on est en train de
voir cette image vous ne voyez pas vous
moi je la vois la mouche est belle et
sur le alors sur la tête de de my pet
sur son front je vous explique un peu ce
qui s'est passé une mouche qui se posent
sur le front de maille peines pendant 2
minutes vous allez me dire j'en parlerai
pas dans la voix si on perd trop lisse
la voie moi politico en a fait un
article
du coup c'est sérieux quand même un en
arctique en dix ans la vraie star du
débat c'est la mouche ça veut dire et
alors qu elle s en est mêlé
eh bien c'est la niña pas bougé minari
soeur va voir son tweet a twitté en part
dans le débat en disant c'est ma tante
qui a gagné et la deuxième c'était la
mouche et et deuxième ça c'est le
premier met en scène avec les le
deuxième tweet c'est bye donne et avec
la à la à mouches à
isaïe simple il est alors plus malin que
ça les démocrates ont lancé flywheel
vote dotcom donc la mouche qui votent
points comme en fait quand vous faites
la mouche qui votent vous tombez sur un
site qui va vous inciter à voter on sait
que la mobilisation c'est le nerf de la
guerre pour les démocrates
donc voilà cqfd c'était la mouche la
star de la mobilisation des démocrates
merci françois elle elle est dingue
cette campagne elle vous fait pas ou pas
oui c'est un peu flippant parce que
c'est vrai que là cette espèce de retour
de donald trump
enfin je veux dire je pense que même
house of cards n'ai pas osé faire autant
de rebondissements on est passé en mer
au sénat risque ne serait pas bien et on
est là ce personnage de roman enfin deux
feuilletons télé qui est assez
angoissant que peut encore gagner votre
avis moi je suis toujours très inquiète
parce qu'à chaque fois on enterre à
chaque fois on pense que c'est perdu
s'est perdu et ont brandi des sondages
et à chaque fois il s'en sort donc chez
un peu inquiète en fait on va s'arrêter
là un mot donné devant d'âge les mauvais
et les catastrophiques
mais il faut rester quand même prudent
mais vous restez avec nous pour suivre
tout ça et même road la de l'élection
jusqu'à l'investiture que là ça fait
merci les amis merci isabelle saporta ge
rappelle le titre choc de votre livre
rendez nous la france en finir avec la
caste et qui paralysent notre pays c'est
chez fayard très belle soirée
documentaire tout de suite avec jean
pierre gratien à demain
[Musique]